Aujourd'hui, c'est la Journée nationale du fromage.
Alors, évidemment, l'une des premières questions
qu'on se pose
c'est pourquoi y a-t-il des trous
dans certains fromages ?
L' emmental est un fromage à pâte
cuite et pressée.
Pendant l'affinage, une armée de micro-organismes découpe les protéines et les lipides contenus dans le lait
et les transforme en arôme notamment.
Des chercheurs suisses ont récemment découvert
qu'il y avait aussi de toutes petites particules de foin
qui en fermentant produisaient du gaz.
Comme l'emmenthal est recouvert
d'une croûte étanche,
ce gaz ne parvient pas à s'échapper.
Il forme des bulles qui deviennent
des trous quand on découpe le fromage.
ça sent bon !
une vraie "capsule de déconfiné"
Allez à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus.
J'en réalise une nouvelle
chaque jour .
Alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné"
abonnez-vous
et activez la petite cloche
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...